hey
everybody's good
all right we're good all right good
morning i'm lieutenant ray spencer i'm
the homicide lieutenant with the las
vegas metropolitan police department
i'm out here this morning to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 600 block of north
11th the details that i have right now
are very preliminary but at around seven
o'clock this morning
metro police received report that a male
had been shot after he had ran
to the front of a 7-eleven that was at
the intersection of bonanza in maryland
parkway
officers arrived that male was
transported to umc trauma where he was
pronounced deceased
he is a hispanic male in his late
twenties what we have learned from the
investigation is that the victim
was walking on 11th street which is
adjacent to the 7-11
when at some point there was an
altercation we do not know if he had an
altercation
with a person on foot or in a vehicle we
are still trying to determine that
we are in the process of canvassing the
area looking for witnesses and we are
also trying to locate any surveillance
video
i urge anybody who has any information
to reach out to crime stoppers
there's reward money available and you
can remain completely anonymous
or you can also reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com
so again still very early on in the
investigation but i'll take a couple
questions if you have them
yes there was a store clerk there was a
citizen who immediately
rendered aid and along again with the
clerk there were two clerks inside
who called 9-1-1 prior to police
arriving so right now we have
the it's a community group called trauma
intervention program
they are out here providing assistance
to the clerk
obviously who was shaken up for what
they witnessed
the victim was shot on 11th street
basically behind the 7-eleven
so and i noticed that pecos was shut
down over at 95.
so the original details that there was
an incident on
in northeast in the northeast area off
of pecos that was thought
potentially was related we have ruled
that out as being related so at this
point we don't believe that has any ins
uh any involvement with us
well we do know that the victim was on
foot
prior to the shooting so we don't know
what
again led up to the shooting as far as
you know
why he was approached or who he
approached we just know he was shot
and then ran into the 7-eleven seeking
help
no there were no weapons found on the
victim
i don't have the specifics on that
still too early we're still trying to
figure out exactly why the victim was in
the area
still don't know so all right thank you
guys
uh we'll be out here probably for the
next couple out two to three hours
before it's opened up
all right thank you
making a movie over here not much to
look at
i'm out of ideas
um
all right we're good yeah all right good
morning i'm lieutenant ray spencer